hi everyone welcome back to plays of the
week brought to you by ochoto tv
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
fight
perfect
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
perfect
okay
[Music]
[Music]
uh
okay
perfect
okay
[Music]
hold me down
[Music]
[Music]
soon
wow
um
[Music]
okay
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
um
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ko
[Music]
[Music]
thanks
oh
foreign
want to be featured in ochoto tv send in
your clips by following these steps
before you submit your clips
make sure the quality of the video is
clear
put your ign as a file name for your
video limit submissions to three to five
clips a week per category
don't spam submissions and don't send
folders with your clips on it avoid
full-length matches or just cut the clip
you want on the desired play until the
end of the round
next send your clips via dropbox in the
correct category
you can always find it on the
description of every other tv series
once you upload your video file if it
prompts you to give your name
just put in your ign
also these are things you can do if
you're sending a recorded replay match
please understand that it may take some
time for some clips to be featured
because of the review process
thanks for watching don't forget to hit
like and be sure to subscribe for more
tekken content
[Music]
you